you can use tungl me to share calendars
with others regardless of their calendar
type here's how first make sure you're
on home in the top menu then select the
contacts icon from the left
sidebar search for the contact you want
to share
with mouse over their name and click
edit
sharing select what you want to share
you have the choice free busy or
calendar detail
TS add a personal message and
send your contact will receive the
request by email they will need a tungle
me account to accept if they don't
already have one they'll be able to
quickly create a free
account once you're
sharing you'll be able to see your
contact schedule overlaid on
yours